♪♪
Touchdown, Jimmy Keene!
Dennis Lehane:
Black Bird is the story of Jimmy
Keene.
He grew up a suburban kid
athlete.
Dennis Lehane:
He liked cars, he liked women.
He’s a very smart guy, charming,
good listener.
Well, what’s your ambition?
♪♪
Taron Egerton:
I think he thought he could walk
on water.
♪♪
It’s the judgement of the court
that the defendant be committed
to one hundred and twenty months.
He’s a very good kid who did
some bad things along the way.
Dad, tell me there’s a way out
of this.
Big Jim:
Not a quick one.
♪♪
He’s offered an opportunity to
redeem himself.
We would like you to transfer to
another prison and befriend
someone to elicit a confession.
♪♪
You want me to check into hell
and befriend a demon.
Not for all the money in the
world.
How about freedom?
♪♪
Larry’s world is a true
darkness, and that’s the world
that Jimmy enters.
♪♪
In my dreams, I like... kill
women.
♪♪
You know?
Sure.
(Thunder)
Larry Hall was a puzzle.
♪♪
It's impossible to understand
his mentality.
♪♪
Why are you looking at me like
that?
♪♪
Like you know me.
Taron Egerton:
Larry gets in his head.
And Jimmy is horrified by it.
Jimmy was in something that was
bigger than him.
Bigger than anything.
Dennis Lehane:
And if he screws this up, this
guy will be out into the world again.
Lauren:
If he walks, he’ll kill again
and again.
♪♪
Jimmy has no protections left.
He has no armor left.
He has nothing.
You think you could be in
danger.
♪♪
James:
Six, one, two!
You are in danger.
♪♪
Larry:
Something’s gonna happen.